listen I'll give you I'll give you a
crazy funny story here we're in the Army
yeah okay
[Laughter]
well you know his name was actually Mark
and he was a sweetheart
we're in Kentucky Tennessee
there's one guy who was a Ohio State
linebacker who didn't make it in the NFL
but he's with us at the army guys
freaking a beast he's a monster and he's
pissed because he's not in the NFL but
he knows how to party and he knows about
clubs and I'm a rookie at this unit he
said I'm gonna take you to a club path
to sick Club connections we go to this
club underground nearly a thousand
people there
it was like Studio 54. the stuff that
happened in this club was unfreaking
believable but it was a drag queen Club
it was a gay club lesbians all of that
at this club right
and half the women that would go there
were single straight they just kind of
wanted to be left alone have a good time
with their girlfriends well after 11
o'clock 12 O'Clock they're kind of a
little bit more open-minded and then
that's when you explore I take one of my
guys
and we were very careful when we took
guys to this club because we were
worried Linda they're going to freak out
or something so this guy goes and a
couple of the guys at this club were
very aggressive I said listen guys I'm
going to be taking you're going to be
protected you're safe with me but I love
girls so just go if we can have that
straight we're good to go great but they
always ask us one question and they got
one of my friends and the question was
this
goes up to this guy and he says hey you
ever been with men no
do you like me says No I like women
he says how do you know
what do you mean how do you know you
don't like men
I'm telling you I like how do you know
you don't like men if you've never been
with men
so it's like it's a great pickup line I
should think it's very impressive okay
yeah so so then we go in the car we got
a 45 minute one hour drive back from
Tennessee from Nashville
and he says
but he's right how would we know that
I'm like bro trust me yeah what are you
doing this is I'm telling you but maybe
how do we know yeah it's like add the
alcohol to it and it's two o'clock in
the morning it's like incredibly that
should have been recorded right yeah you
know what I got to find out you have to
go to find out for himself no no I'm
like dude what are you doing okay
anyways we had another guy was he yeah
well he's not gay at least we don't
think he's gay but that's all he knows
but now he knows he's not sorry okay so
he's straighter than us yeah in the end
he knows he's straight we don't know
yeah
[Laughter]
it's hard to only sleep with one woman
you're a very good looking guy your eyes
are freaking ridiculous
you know this I don't need to tell you
this you're a very handsome guy no but
but the point with me is Mike if we're
gonna say are you serious
that's me every week I'm like really I'm
waiting for the bit to be up
yeah so you've seen someone get flipped
and you saw how easy it was but by the
way you know what I say tonight you know
what I say today yeah that's totally
fine yeah why is that fun he's 18 years
old freedom
respect this is your Chelsea Handler
story I saw someone get flipped to me
it's go for it you made it I don't need
to know that yeah I don't need to know
everything do you feel some guilt that
your friend was sucking dick in a
Kentucky nightclub because they brought
him there but he would have never done
it the funnier story was another guy we
would always be fried chicken
I will tell you that the funniest of all
stories was this one guy every time we
take a shower he was Rock Solid what
what what and we would always say I
would say hey bro what's up wait wait
you had to ask him you know what's up
but it wasn't like it was like you know
maybe like you just got done with your
girl and you're coming you come and take
a shower okay good respect yeah but it's
kind of like every time and it's like
right like like dude that's crazy you
know six months later we found out why
why he was a boy he was bisexual so he
like guys so he would see other guys in
Sean like listen moving forward you got
shower nine to ten we're gonna come at
10 o'clock or eight o'clock well your
shift is this time it was like we
laughed about it by the way he's married
today with two kids okay and probably
best looking guy at the unit okay but he
was buying guess what over 18 your
choice do what you got to do under 18
yeah let's not confuse our kids that is
the only thing I'm saying and if your
kid if you think your kid is gay and
your kid is part of the anomaly
community that our genius friend here is
talking about the one percenter we're
gonna come we're gonna get by the way we
can give him shirts one percent okay
yeah and that's that Community guess
what
you can have a
specific class just for somebody that's
there no problem now question yeah if we
continue to have anomalies throughout
history right
if it continues
is it anomaly is an anomaly
no if it continues throughout history
and it should weed itself out because
they can't procreate
if they're having gay sex if it
continues is it a nominal Society we've
done a lot to try to get rid of it
I've been around forever no no it has it
has that being said there are other
things within I I guess I know that
people are going to take are not right
though like in Iran there was a famous
comedian who's a very well known a lot
of people dead this guy was a famous
comedian incredible on TV entertaining
but rumor said it he liked men yeah and
they killed him that's not cool at all
that is not at all what we're talking
about here but just because history did
that doesn't mean let's make up for it
by going and converting a bunch of other
people to it all I'm saying is you're
18.
you want to go do this go forward you
want to go do that go for it I'm not
going to sit there and tell you
here's what you ought to consider doing
[Music]